first off she seems like she's a sex  addict because she says she's a sex  addict she's obviously a drug addict  she's obviously someone who has been  damaged in her life she obviously  resents her father a whole lot seems  like she was molested as a child we do  not know by whom just to be clear this  is the exact girl i would hit on  yes  and she wrote this i remember having sex  with friends at a young age  showers with my dad and in parentheses  probably not appropriate what thanks for  adding that  um was it i don't know if they brought  it up i asked him to bring it up uh  token and make sure we get it from the  control room hunter biden he was sexting  with his niece if i'm not mistaken and  then he had a picture with an underage  girl who was not his niece but he was  definitely sexting with his niece she's  showering i mean incest just seems to  run in the biden family there were